N
CHILDREN IN THE MIDST OF THIS.
JOINING US NOW WITH REACTION IS
FORMER HOMICIDE DETECTIVE AND
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR TED
WILLIAMS.
AND THE COAST OF THE BUCK SEXTON
AND CLAY TRAVIS SHOW,
BUCK SEXTON, WHO IS ALSO A
FORMER MEMBER OF THE NYPD'S
INTELLIGENCE DIVISION.
GENTLEMEN -- TED, LET ME START
WITH YOU.
IT'S GOOD TO SEE YOU.
CLEARLY THEY ARE STILL MORNING
AND THERE IS STILL SADNESS AND
GRIEVING AND THERE'S NOW SOME
RAGE AS WE GET MORE INFORMATION,
BECAUSE WE'VE GOT TO KNOW THIS
INFORMATION IN ORDER TO KNOW
WHAT TO DO AND WHAT GOES WRONG
AND WHAT WE CAN FIX.
TELL ME YOUR THOUGHTS NOW WITH
WHAT WE ARE SEEING AND HOW THIS
IS UNFOLDING FOR US SO FAR.
>> AS YOU'VE ALREADY SAID, WE DO
HAVE TO GET THIS INFORMATION,
AND WE HAVE TO GET IT RIGHT AND
WE NEED TO KNOW THE TRUTH OF
WHAT TOOK PLACE.
WE WERE TOLD YESTERDAY IN A
PRESS CONFERENCE BY THE GOVERNOR
AND THE HEAD OF THE
TEXAS RANGERS AND THE LIEUTENANT
GOVERNOR AND OTHER OFFICIALS
THERE THAT THE FIRST PERSON TO
COME IN CONTACT WITH THIS KILLER
WAS A SECURITY OFFICER AT THAT
BACK DOOR.
THE BACKDOOR WE NOW NOW LEARNED
WAS UNLOCKED.
WE ALSO NOW KNOW THAT THERE WAS
NO SECURITY OFFICER, AND WE ALSO
KNOW THAT BY THE TIME THIS GUY
GOT INTO THAT SCHOOL, INTO THAT
ROOM, THERE WAS GUNSHOTS, AND
THEN THIS GUY WAS IN THERE FOR
ONE HOUR.
AND I'D LIKE YOU TO THINK ABOUT
THIS AND I'D LIKE OUR AUDIENCE
TO THINK ABOUT THIS.
YOU HAD 19 CHILDREN THAT HAD
BEEN SHOT AND YOU HAD 17 OR MORE
THAT HAD BEEN INJURED, AND THOSE
KIDS WERE IN THERE FOR ONE HOUR
WITH THIS KILLER AND THOSE WHO
ARE NOW LIVING, I AM SURE,
TAMMY, THAT THEY ARE SCARRED AND
PERHAPS SCARRED FOR LIFE, AND
WHAT SHOULD HAVE HAPPENED, WHAT
SHOULD HAVE HAPPENED IS WHAT
HAPPENED 23 YEARS AGO.
WE LEARNED A LESSON AT
COLUMBINE, AND THAT IS, TO GO
IN, THE LAW ENFORCEMENT, AND
NEUTRALIZE THE PERSON RIGHT
AWAY.
THAT DID NOT HAPPEN HERE.
THEY GAVE US FALSE INFORMATION
YESTERDAY AND AS A RESULT OF
THAT, UNFORTUNATELY, SOME KIDS
MAY HAVE BEEN SAVED -- WE DON'T
KNOW THAT BUT THERE COULD HAVE
BEEN SOME PEOPLE SAY.
>> Tammy: WE KNOW, BUCK, JUST
FROM THIS REPORT FROM
"THE WALL STREET JOURNAL" IF
IT'S ACCURATE, A MOM GOES INTO
THE ARENA, GETS INTO THE
BUILDING IN THE MIDST OF ALL OF
THIS, ACCESSES THE BUILDING,
FINDS HER CHILDREN, REMOVES THEM
FROM THE BUILDING -- AGAIN, THIS
IS FROM HER REPORT,
"WALL STREET JOURNAL" REPORTING
WHAT SHE'S TOLD THEM, AND
RESCUED HER OWN CHILDREN, A MOM
DID THIS.
THIS IS ALSO -- WHEN WE THINK
ABOUT THE GOVERNOR, PERHAPS THEY
WERE GIVEN THE WRONG
INFORMATION, THAT IT LOOKS LIKE
THE LOCAL POLICE REPORT -- THEY
WERE REPORTING -- NOBODY SEEMS
TO HAVE THE CORRECT INFORMATION
AT ALL.
WHAT DO YOU THINK WITH YOUR
BACKGROUND IN INTELLIGENCE AND
WHAT'S REQUIRED HERE?
I KNOW IT'S A SMALL TOWN.
NO ONE IS GOING TO FORGIVE
THEMSELVES FOR THE REST OF THEIR
LIVES.
WE DON'T WANT TO PILE ON HERE,
BUT WE MUST NOTE THE NATURE OF
WHAT MISSTEPS WERE TAKEN.
>> THAT'S ABSOLUTELY RIGHT,
BECAUSE IT'S ESSENTIAL THAT WE
DO WHAT'S NECESSARY GOING
FORWARD TO TRY TO PREVENT AND
CERTAINLY MITIGATE TO THE
GREATEST DEGREE POSSIBLE A
SITUATION LIKE THIS.
AND I JUST SAY THAT THE TIMELINE
OF WHAT WE KNOW RIGHT NOW
OCCURRED FROM LAW ENFORCEMENT
PERSPECTIVE RESPONSE IS JUST
UNACCEPTABLE.
IT'S TOO LONG, IT'S TOO SLOW, SO
I UNDERSTAND THEY ARE SAYING
THERE ARE ADDITIONAL DETAILS
THAT NEED TO COME OUT, BUT THE
FACT OF THE MATTER IS JUST BASED
UPON WHAT HAS ALREADY BEEN
CONFIRMED, THEY HAD AN ACTIVE
SHOOTER WHO WAS STILL SHOOTING
OVER THE COURSE OF THAT HOUR OF
THE WEIGHT WHILE HE WAS INSIDE
AND THE PRIOR POINT WAS ALREADY
MADE THAT THERE MAY HAVE BEEN
CHILDREN WHO WERE HIT, WHO WERE
BLEEDING OUT.
SPEED IS ABSOLUTELY OF THE
ESSENCE AND THAT YOU COULD HAVE
HAD AS MANY AS AROUND 100
LAW-ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS ON THE
SCENE SETTING UP A CORDON AND
PREVENTING PARENTS FROM GOING IN
AND THEN A PARENT ACTUALLY
MANAGES TO GET IN AND SAVE HER
OWN CHILDREN JUST GOES TO SHOW
YOU THIS WAS A BREAKDOWN AND
PEOPLE ARE GOING TO BE STUDYING
THIS IN THE LAW-ENFORCEMENT
COMMUNITY FOR A LONG TIME I
THINK ABOUT JUST HOW COMMAND AND
CONTROL ON THE SCENE, WHAT
TACTICS, TECHNIQUES AND
PROCEDURES NEED TO CHANGE HERE,
WHAT WAS THE BREAKDOWN, HOW DID
THIS OCCUR, BECAUSE NOBODY WOULD
EVER LOOK AT THIS, STUDY THIS
SITUATION FROM A PURE
LAW ENFORCEMENT PERSPECTIVE AND
SAY THIS IS THE WAY -- THIS IS
THE PLAYBOOK, THIS IS HOW WE ARE
SUPPOSED TO RESPOND IN THIS
CIRCUMSTANCE.
I KNOW IT'S A SMALL TOWN, THEY
DON'T HAVE A LOT OF RESOURCES
BUT THEY HAD A LOT OF ARMED
PERSONNEL ON THE SCENE AND
118-YEAR-OLD WITH A RIFLE.
>> Tammy: TAD, WE SAW SOME OF
THIS ALSO WHEN IT CAME TO THE
PARKLAND SHOOTING.
CLEARLY THAT PLAYED OUT WHERE WE
KNOW ABOUT SCHOOL RESOURCE
OFFICER HIDING, DIFFERENT POLICE
DEPARTMENT COMING IN TO FINALLY
MOVE IN THAT ENVIRONMENT, THAT
WHAT HAPPENS ON THE GROUND CAN
BE SHOCKING.
THESE ARE PEOPLE WHO ARE TRAINED
TO DO SOMETHING.
YOU HAVE TO WONDER.
IT'S LIKE OUR POLICE AFFECTED BY
THE RHETORIC WITHIN HEARING FOR
YEARS ABOUT LAW ENFORCEMENT?
IS THIS A DYNAMIC THAT THERE
NEEDS TO BE MASSIVE NATIONAL
RETRAINING ABOUT HOW TO RESPOND
TO A VIOLENT INCIDENT?
BUT IT SEEMS STRANGE THAT WHEN
EVEN -- ESPECIALLY CHILDREN ARE
INVOLVED, SCHOOLS IN THIS
DYNAMIC, PARKLAND AND NOW HERE,
THAT THINGS WERE NOT DONE WHEN
THEY COULD HAVE BEEN DONE.
WHAT DO YOU THINK, TED?
, IS AT
THE CORE OF THIS RETICENCE AND
PROBLEM?
>> YOU KNOW, LISTEN, IN DEFENSE
OF THE POLICE, THERE'S ALWAYS A
GREAT DEAL OF CONFUSION WHEN YOU
HAVE THESE KINDS OF UNFORTUNATE
EVENTS.
BUT THERE WERE KIDS IN THERE.
THESE LAW-ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS
KNEW THAT THERE WERE KIDS IN
THERE, AND THESE KIDS SHOULD
HAVE BEEN IMMEDIATELY -- THERE
SHOULD HAVE BEEN AN ATTEMPT TO
RESCUE THEM.
EVEN IF YOU WOULD HAVE TRIED TO
BREACH THE DOOR, THEY SHOULD
HAVE HAD SOME KIND OF WAY TO TRY
TO GET INTO THAT ROOM AND THEY
SHOULD HAVE GOT IN RIGHT AWAY.
YOU COULD NOT WAIT AN HOUR.
JUST THINK ABOUT IT, YOUNG KIDS
AND THEIR TERRIBLY UPSET BECAUSE
THEY WAITED ONE HOUR BEFORE
GOING IN THERE TO TRY TO RESCUE
THEM.
>> Tammy: ABSOLUTELY SHOCKING.
BUCK, I WILL GIVE YOU THE LAST
WORD HERE.
EVERY DAY IS GOING TO BRING NEW
INFORMATION.
EVERYONE INVOLVED IS SHOCKED AND
STRUGGLING WITH HOW THEY ACTED
AND WHAT HAPPENED.
WHERE DO YOU THINK WE GO FROM
HERE?
>> UNFAMILIAR WITH HOW
BUREAUCRACIES WORK, INCLUDING
LAW-ENFORCEMENT BUREAUCRACIES,
AND I THINK THAT SOME OF THE
REPORTED INFORMATION THAT TURNED
OUT TO BE INCORRECT, THERE'S A
BIT OF A SCRAMBLING GOING ON
AMONG SOME OF THE AUTHORITIES
INVOLVED HERE TO COME UP WITH
WHAT THE NARRATIVE WILL BE THAT
DOESN'T END UP SOUNDING LIKE A
LOT OF COP STOOD AROUND WITH
SCREAMING PARENTS SAYING SAVE
OUR CHILDREN INSIDE, THERE'S A
MANIAC MURDERING THEM, I THINK
THAT'S HONESTLY -- THE TAKE AWAY
HERE IS GOING TO BE THAT THEY
DON'T REALLY WANT TO GET THE
INFORMATION OUT THERE QUICKLY
BECAUSE THE INFORMATION OF THE
RESPONSE HERE IS NOT GOOD.
THE LAW-ENFORCEMENT SPOTS --
WITH THE EXCEPTION OF THE BORDER
PATROL TACTICAL TEAM THAT WENT
IN THERE AND ENDED THE THREAT.
>> Tammy: THANK YOU,
GENTLEMEN, THIS COMES DOWN TO NO
MATTER WHAT KIND OF A PLAN YOU
MIGHT HAVE, NO MATTER HOW MUCH
MONEY, WHAT THE STRATEGIES ARE,
IT COMES DOWN TO THE HUMANITY,
TH